A St Remy Vidéo, venez acquérir un film pour un jour, ou même deux.
Et profitez d'un panel de film incroyable.
Des films.
Mais aussi des séries.
Nous ne possédons pas la dernière saison de Game of Thrones,
mais si vous êtes amateur d'Heroic Fantasy, je vous conseille la série Xena la Guerrière.
Une soudaine envie d'avoir accès à des dizaines de films ?
De films? Ah pas du tout, de l'extérieur j'ai cru que c'était un micromania.
Vous êtes pas...
Non.
Profitez d'un service personnalisé, à la personne.
Oui Monsieur Bianchi, vos dvds viennent d'arriver, ils vous attendent.
Ok très bien, d'accord.
Mais euh... On parle bien des films pornos, hein ?
Allô ?
St Rémy Vidéo, c'est l'accès le plus rapide à des dizaines de vidéos.
Après internet.
Connaissez-vous l'acteur... Jean Reno ?
Micromania ?
Ouais...
Non.